cette aventure lyme qui qui produit
koh-lanta oui à paris qui appartient à
votre votre société c'est un peu mou le
patron de radio non j'ai pas du tout
patine enfin c'est en tout cas c'est
pourquoi vous ne créez pas moins de
l'attraction que l'on t'a enfants
amoureux les épreuves d'orientation et
pose ici sans à l'eau fiji quoi le faire
de l'accrobranche je vais vous raconter
quelque chose de vous dire arrêter j'ai
je suis allé voir le maire de cannes de
la ville de cagnes à l'année dernière
qui est très sympathique et je lui dis
pourquoi parce qu'ils savent lire un
énorme terrain je dis pourquoi on
créerait pas un énorme parc
d'attractions destiné à la télévision
c'est à dire que on viendrait on ferait
un l'immense n'oubliez pas les paroles
naïves ans parcours de koh lanta on
ferait exactement quel est le feraient
les épreuves de fort boyard onfray voilà
alors sachez que c'est un énorme budget
des combats bien entendu mais il était
assez intéressé après bien sûr il
faudrait presque le le coc vide tout ça
donc voilà mais je suis gt gt de boire
avec ses conseillers
on est même allé voir le terrain où son
loyer ou pas bon et moi et c'est vrai
que voilà c'est ça c'est jean michel a
tous envie de savoir rhinoise des mais
c'est un investissement colossal à tous
les maîtres forcément voilà et donc soit
si on veut faire c'est un investissement
colossal mais je suis sûr que les
téléspectateurs grego à oui et je vous
le dis et je n'avais pas envie et l
expression c'est un mec super parce
qu'on voulait faire en fait vous voulez
pas faire payer les sommes énormes en
riant vous voulez voilà que ce soit très
peu coûteux et donc il faut essayer de
voir comment ne pas perdre d'argent
parce qu'on voulait pas vous voulez ne
pas perdre d'argent et lui voilà il
s'est dit moi lâche pas dire que ce soit
trop trop cher et moi aussi voilà pour
les personnes qui viennent soutenir ces
de tous les jeux partout
donc voilà les faire on voulait faire un
koh lanta faire venir voilà même parfois
les vrais animateurs viendrait des
anciens les anciens candidats et cetera
coup pour y affronter koh lanta fort
boyard n'oubliez pas les paroles
voilà
on va laisser ouais on doit laisser
exactement voulais faire aussi ramener
tous les marseillais voilà parce que
c'étaient des mots possibles on ya pensé
voilà mais en tout cas c'est un truc
voilà mais c'est un investissement
on est en train d'étudier le truc mais
c'est passé c'est long mais ces petits
voiliers que c'est pas con beaux jours
me voilà pour rire ça c'est vraiment pas
content